welcome back to cbs mornings we're
bringing you the story today of a man
who has spent decades in prison for a
crime he says he did not commit his name
is vincent simmons he's serving a
100-year prison sentence in louisiana
after being convicted of attempted
aggravated rape of two 14 year old twin
sisters back in 1977 but there have
always been unanswered questions in this
case and a judge is about to rule on
whether simmons will get a new trial
lead national correspondent david begno
spent months reporting on this story and
he's got some new developments that
could change this case david joins us
now good morning to you david good
morning gail what you are about to hear
the jury never heard
starting with the initial report that
the twins gave to police about who they
say sexually assaulted them
a questionable photo the forensic exam
conducted by a doctor on the twins
and then we have an explosive revelation
that no one has heard
until we started investigating this
story
in the rural center of louisiana
there has been a haunting question
hanging over marksville for decades did
vincent simmons get a fair trial in 1977
when he was convicted of a heinous crime
against 14 year old twin sisters he
raped two of us
and he put us in a trunk
to die
he had me write our names down and he
told us he was going to kill us
and we believed every word of it
and we were not going to tell anyone
our plan was
we were going to die with this but two
weeks later word got to the sheriff
and that is when karen and sharon
sanders reluctantly reported some
details claiming they were forcibly
taken by a black man to a country road
and sexually assaulted for three hours
in a car that belonged to their 18 year
old cousin keith labord while he was
locked in the trunk we called him
simmons all night there's so many things
about that night he gave us his name
when you were questioned by the sheriff
yes you never gave the name simmons no
we did not you never described what he
looked like no we did not you said all
blacks look alike and you said all in
words that's right sure did so how are
we to square the fact that that night
you couldn't explain anything you didn't
have his name you didn't know what he
looked like but now you're telling me
today and you testified at trial that
his name was simmons that's right how
does that happen okay this is how it
happens
we had all three
swore to each other that we would not
tell a soul
may i ask you with all due respect yes
why did you make that pact to not say
anything why would you immediately
report it because we were scared he told
us that he had friends and that he would
come back to kill us if we told anybody
67 days after he was arrested simmons
who was known to police as a petty thief
was sentenced to 100 years in prison
convicted at 25 years old of attempted
aggravated rape by a jury of 11 white
men and one black woman the first thing
i want to say to you is that i know my
client is innocent justin bonus is the
latest attorney to take up seven's case
he filed a motion to have simmons
released this was a legal mention he is
waiting for a louisiana judge to rule
next week on whether or not simmons is
entitled to a new trial there's no
physical evidence that connects them to
that crime there's no blood there's no
semen
there's no hairs
there's nothing
sharon talks about bleeding all over the
car karen talks about a violent rape
where's the evidence in the car where's
the blood in the car there's nothing
that supports a crime happen and there's
definitely not anything sports that a
black man committed the crime this is
important for the viewers to know a
month or so ago the d.a offered to
release him but he wanted him to
register as a sex offender and what did
vincent say to you no
why
he didn't do this
so he turned down freedom correct
because a sex offender registrant
meant
that much to him correct that he didn't
want to do it correct he's not a sex
offender this is the man who offered to
release him the current district
attorney charlie riddle why did you
offer to release mrs because today
40 years would probably be the sentence
that we would request in a case like
this this box this box this instead
riddle is now left to defend a case that
based on new information raises more
questions about whether simmons is
guilty years after going to prison
simmons obtained the district attorney's
evidence file about the case in it he
claims he found a revealing medical
report from the local coroner a trained
doctor who examined the twins that
report was never introduced at trial one
of the attorneys who was vincent's
defense attorney at the time of trial he
says they never knew that the coroner
said you were a virgin
that the coroner said there was no
evidence of sexual assault found on
either one of you okay well i didn't
know that well it's two weeks later and
it's still not important the fact is
he still attempted
and he wasn't successful so he still
raped me and he did rape her so how do
you react though when the report
essentially says i don't care because
evidence of sexual assault because it
doesn't matter there was because we know
by now i think if we were lying we would
have given up but i'm not giving up
in 1994 simmons took the medical
examination report to a parole board we
didn't have none of this evidence none
of this evidence was presented before
the jury because the deed had it in his
files it testified before the jury that
they were brutally raped they repeatedly
asked them would they be able to
identify this person again if they saw
him to say no because all blacks look
alike and he presented another piece of
evidence that he found in the file
he says this is a lineup photo showing
him in handcuffs this is a joke it's a
joke it doesn't get any more suggestive
than this did the two of you and keith
all pick vincent simmons out of the
lineup yes we all three did the lineup
shows him in handcuffs
yeah it sure does and that's been a big
problem
because when we
picked him he was not in handcuffs i'm
telling you that the deputies that were
there and present and the victims say
that he was never in handcuffs when they
identified him so is it possible that
you made a mistake
when you picked him in the lineup
david
i have lived 44 years
with his
face and my brain and there is no way
that i would have spent 44 years if i
had the slightest
doubt in my mind that i did not have the
right man in prison
we wanted to speak with the prosecutor
who got simmons convicted about
allegations that he withheld evidence
that may have exonerated summons david
begno here for eddie knoll
though he repeatedly declined to speak
with us
former district attorney eddie knowl
says in a sworn affidavit that the
defense had access to the entire file he
says he is convinced the evidence
supported simmons conviction
and about that photo he says he was told
it was taken after the lineup so it was
information that is
explosively helpful for a lawyer to use
before she became a louisiana criminal
court judge lori white represented
simmons and tried to get him a new trial
it was pretty clear to me that the
defense
did not have information to impeach the
witnesses they did not have the police
report they did not have that photograph
of a physical lineup they did not have
what was a rape kit at that time for the
coroner to have uh physically looked at
the two alleged victims had a jury heard
i don't think they would have convicted
or they would not have convicted perhaps
of that charge
he did it he just didn't you know
it is among 16 unsuccessful attempts to
get his conviction tossed out the board
has voted this time to deny your quest
for ruling now it is attorney justin
bonas turn you already have a judge who
said to you on the record
that mr simmons was convicted without
the total picture
do you believe you're on the verge of
getting a new trial
i pray that i am
i don't know what to believe until it
happens i don't know what to believe
attorney justin bonus has told the judge
overseeing the case about what he calls
explosive new evidence from a sworn
affidavit made by keith labored's cousin
dana bruyette dana bruyette says long
after the trial keith admitted to me
that vincent simmons did not rape sharon
and karen and did not put them in the
trunk of the car dana bruyette goes on
to say he told me that he had had
consensual sex with one of the girls and
locked the other in the trunk while he
was on little california oh my god she
is a sick woman she has no clue say that
was the truth
and they believed that really happened
why didn't they go report it hello mr la
board
my name is david begno with cbs news
keith labord was not home when we
stopped by
by phone he refused our request for an
interview he insisted that simmons is
guilty and he says he did not have sex
with karen the sheriff asked you if you
had been sexually involved with keith
and you told him no
it's an uncomfortable question
so i'm pausing because i don't even like
asking it go for it
i know you're already there i know i
know that's fine did you have consensual
sex with keith labor
we were kids yes ma'am
we experimented
so yes if that's consensual if that's
what whatever word you want to put to it
this happened before you say vincent
simmons raped you yes how old were you
when it happened i don't know 9
10 maybe
and is this the first time you're saying
this publicly
yes it is
that's as newly discovered evidence as
it gets man and it's out of the horse's
mouth she's no longer a victim my
client's a victim it's evidence that
vincent at trial his defense attorneys
would have ran to that
so fast they would have blamed keith now
that we know
that this guy was preying on her and she
for the first time reveals this
it calls into question everything that
she said before everything one thing has
nothing to do with the other thing yeah
we were young we experimented but that
has nothing to do with what vincent did
that's two
separate incidents that's two separate
things the twins insist they are the
victims wounded by what happened and
they blame the legal system for not
ensuring that simmons unanimous
conviction was irrefutable
they know the challenge that they're
facing my thing is this because of what
maybe should have been done that wasn't
done the things we should have said and
we didn't say also and what we didn't
say our word is against his there's no
evidence and it would be hard to fight
it if the judge orders a new trial are
you both willing to testify at the trial
oh absolutely i will testify karen
no
i will not i'm not i'm not doing it i'm
not i'm not i've already been there
we've done this
why am i going to put myself
in that position again and take the
chance of him walking out because right
now anyway we're at a 50 50 that he
could walk out anyway so if we go to
court we're still at the same odds i'm
not going to put myself and my family
back through you
back through that because either
don't you get it it doesn't matter
because if we don't and we back down now
then it gives the world more of an
opportunity to say they're lying and
that's why they're backing
doesn't matter anymore the world's going
to think what they want to think no
matter how hard we fight it doesn't
matter it does matter it doesn't
i want him to be miserable for the rest
of his remaining days guess what there's
coming a day when he'll stand before god
and he will be miserable
he's already been judged
guilty
he will die guilty and when he goes and
he stands before the lord he will still
be guilty
okay
all right karen
so here's what happens next next monday
a judge will decide whether or not to
grant vincent simmons a new trial
that judge has already said that there's
a constitutional violation in which
simmons was convicted without all of the
evidence being given to his defense team
if the judge declares a new trial
sources say the district attorney will
not retry vincent simmons
because he believes
he'd probably lose
so let me get this straight keith is the
cousin that's right and originally it
was reported that keith was locked in
the car that's right and now we're
finding out that keith
had apparently had sex with one of the
sisters that was never revealed karen
says that keith denies it
there is a air of racism that hangs over
this whole case
i'm curious whether the sisters
said to you
in a different clip that oh they're not
racist yes they used the n word yes they
said all black people look alike but
that's not them
did they deny that in any way the
sisters do not believe they are racist
they admitted saying all black people
all n words look alike and they say it
um
without sort of wincing right uh growing
up in south louisiana i can tell you
back in 1977 with the kkk where it was
there definitely are hints of racism in
various parts of the state was racism
baked into this one of the jurors the
only black woman who was on that case
says when she walked into the room she
said the white men looked at me and they
said doesn't matter what you think he's
guilty i'm still stunned by the cousin
revelation
uh
yeah that's stunning
and no physical evidence
connect that yeah spellbound david
amazing reporting as always thank you
very much